let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 starting today with our caller from
the 907 area code who's calling today
from 907 hey David it's me that is you
indeed who is this I'm Milo Milo what's
going on yep yeah so my question is
about medicare-for-all
so um a really common right wing and
quite frankly you know a talking point
also from like a lot of centrist
Democrats is that you know
medicare-for-all really only works in
countries with like smaller populations
like when I bring up that it works in
like Sweden or Norway or Finland or
other Nordic countries they say like oh
you know those countries have like
relatively smaller populations but in a
country like America with like 320
million plus people it can't work yeah
so I'm just wondering like how do you
rebut that point well first of all with
90% of the people who say that you just
say why not
why would more people make it not work
and usually so that'll get rid of 90%
90% won't have an answer the other 10%
will have some answer and then typically
you know I mean the best thing is not to
rebut it with some concocted talking
point but just to tell the truth which
is the way that insurance works the
larger the risk pool the more
predictable the spending is going to be
per person and that actually having more
people in the risk pool makes the system
more financially viable that you have
way more people who are paying into the
system and that it will actually make
health care spending significantly more
predictable and that there's there's
simply no reason to say that it only
works in smaller countries I mean is is
mathematically untrue and it's logically
untrue right yeah and also just like
sort of one other quick question I had
one of and I think Kyle kolinsky also
brought up this point recently which is
that one sort of I guess solution to
that worry or you know another way we
could sort of do it in America is you
sort of federally mandated each
individual state implemented like on the
state level of sure so
population is no longer a worry that
I've actually mentioned this before this
is a really good point if you book if
you want to make a states rights sort of
positive version of Medicare for all
you actually have each state you could
argue that states for geographical
reasons or because some states have
these like cancer alley factories have
higher rates of certain conditions you
can actually say that different states
may actually need slightly different
financial characteristics and that each
state could implement their own
single-payer system partially subsidized
by the federal government through the
sort of taxation that Bernie Sanders for
example has proposed that's a fantastic
idea mm-hmm right all right well yeah
thanks for answering my question Davis
all right appreciate the call thank you
very very important stuff great to hear
from you